alors j'ai ramené quelque chose avec moi
que j'ai ici dans ma poche et qui
pourrait littéralement changer toute
votre vie
alors j'envoie certains qui sont
sceptiques et qui se disent une mallette
remplie d'argent ça tient pas dans une
poche
et d'autres qui sourient un chèque
alors c'est ni l'un ni l'autre vous
voulez savoir ce que c'est
non je vais vous lire à la fin
entre temps je vais vous raconter une
petite histoire et cette histoire elle
débute quand j'ai 6 ans et à 6 ans je me
souviens exactement du moment où ma prof
me dit Mohamed et pas c'est bon on va te
mettre dans le groupe des moyens pour la
lecture
et moi j'ai 6 ans à ce moment-là j'ai
l'impression que j'ai le bloqué toute ma
vie dans le groupe des moyens et je
pourrai jamais faire mieux
et comme j'ai 6 ans
je dis OK
quelques années plus tard à 12 ans je
suis plutôt bon à l'école et très bon en
science et tout le monde autour de moi
dit ah mais c'est sûr tu vas finir
scientifique moi j'ai 12 ans alors je
dis OK
quelques années plus tard c'est la nuit
du bac j'ai 17 ans et mon prof principal
me dit cash
ne choisit pas de faire une prépa parce
que tu vas échouer
et moi j'ai 17 ans j'ai encore jeune
alors je dis OK
un peu plus tard à 19 ans
je me pose la question et je me demande
est-ce que je devrais pas changer de
domaine d'étude je faisais la chimie à
l'époque
et j'ai un pote qui me dit moi-même tu
vas pas tout lâcher pour te lancer dans
un truc que tu connais même pas
il y a 19 ans
je dis OK
à 22 ans étudiant j'arrive sur Paris et
cherche un appart
et j'avais quelques jours justement pour
chercher ta part
je trouve une chambre de bonne et il
faut le dire dans un état piteux
minuscule avec une minuscule fenêtre qui
s'ouvrait par le haut et qui donnait sur
le couloir pour donner une idée de la
part
et le gars me dit celui qui me proposait
la chambre de bonne mais dit vous avez
une semaine
à ce prix là sur Paris vous allez pas
trouver mieux
et moi j'ai 22 ans
j'ai pas le temps
j'ai pas d'argent
alors je dis OK
à 27 ans je suis chercheur pour l'une
des plus grandes boîtes pharmaceutiques
au monde ouais j'ai à l'étranger et je
suis entouré de personnes extrêmement
talentueuse
et je pars voir mon boss pour lui dire
que je quitte tout que j'arrête tout
j'ai passé ma vie
à écouter les autres et passer ma vie à
laisser décider les autres pour moi et
dans cette histoire j'avais l'impression
qu'il me manquait quelque chose et ce
quelque chose c'était moi dans cette
équation presque parfaite entre la vie
civet et le rêve que j'avais imaginé
plus petit il manquait moi
et donc quand on bosse me répond Ahmed
je veux pas te laisser partir on a mis
tellement d'argent sur le projet que tu
dois rester
à 27 ans
je lui réponds
non
et il m'a fallu 27 ANNÉES 27 longues
années pour reprendre les reines de ma
destinée elle contrôle sur ma vie
et je suis pas le seul dans ce cas il y
a peut-être des personnes ici même dans
cette salle qui ont été ou qui sont dans
le même mois
il est bien là le problème parce que
j'ai été dans mon cas extrêmement
chanceux
cette histoire m'a permis de me dépasser
mais aussi m'a permis de me passionner
pour un domaine qui me passionne
toujours aujourd'hui ici en mais
qu'est-ce qui en est des autres
ces autres personnes qui essaient de se
convaincre jour après jour
malgré les souffrances malgré les
privations et malgré les douleurs que
cette histoire c'est la leur
et bien ces personnes elles meurt à
petit feu du discours qui se sont
imposés et qu'il leur a imposé très tôt
et à cause de ça le taux de mortalité
augmente chaque année
parce qu'en réalité il y a deux moments
où on est on a le plus de chance d'être
soi-même quand on est très petit parce
qu'à ce moment-là on a pas encore eu une
influence ni l'emprise des autres sur
nous et quand on est très vieux
parce qu'à ce moment-là on se rend
compte un peu trop tard
qu'on aurait dû vivre une autre vie
selon nos propres termes
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe entre ces
deux moments pourquoi il si peu sincère
avec nous-mêmes prends ce trahi de cette
façon
et la plus grande des trahison c'est
encore celle qu'on a invers soi-même
pourquoi on essaye d'être poli avec les
autres alors qu'on devrait être
respectueux
pourquoi on est trop de on essaie d'être
sérieux au lieu d'être sincère avec ce
qu'on fait pourquoi on cherche être
différent au lieu d'être authentique
la réponse elle est plutôt simple on
nous impose ce masque social depuis
tellement longtemps tellement longtemps
qu'on finit par se convaincre nous-mêmes
que ce masque c'est notre vrai visage il
y a des personnes qui passent leur vie
entière avec ce masque et ensuite qui se
demande pourquoi ils arrivent pas à
trouver ce confort dans cette vie
pourquoi ils arrivent pas trop le bon
job pourquoi ils arrivent pas à voir de
bonnes relations amicales familiales ou
amoureuses pourquoi ils arrivent pas à
être passionné
tout simplement parce que ces personnes
là
elles vivent une histoire qui n'est pas
la leur elle vive des aventures dont une
ne devrait même pas être le héros
pour vous donner une idée de la
puissance de l'histoire et du récit
Disney l'entreprise va investir 33
milliards cette année pour vous raconter
des histoires
pour vous raconter des histoires
elle le fait parce qu'elle est
convaincue et persuadé qu'on va
s'abreuver et qu'on va consommer ces
récits
voilà à quel point l'histoire est
puissante
Gandhi disait
si vous voulez changer le monde
commencez par vous-même alors de la même
façon si vous voulez changer l'Histoire
avec un grand H commencez par votre
propre histoire
alors comment on redevient souverain de
son propre récit
quand on laisse les autres être l'auteur
de notre propre histoire on passe d'une
condition d'existence où l'on vit à une
condition de subsistance où l'on survit
quand on laisse les autres être l'auteur
de notre propre histoire
on se laisse doucement aspirer par une
faim il mord certaines
alors que lorsqu'on redevient auteur
justement de cette histoire on devient
inspiré inspiré par cette vie
alors comment justement
comment vous donner justement ces points
qui sont essentiels
pour redevenir l'auteur et le héros de
votre propre aventure ici je vais vous
donner quatre points essentiels le
premier c'est celui d'apprendre à des
apprendre
la première des choses que j'ai faites
lorsque j'ai quitté ma carrière de
chercheur c'est de me poser les
questions sur qui j'étais réellement sur
mes valeurs c'est une façon pour moi de
délier le vrai du faux parce que je
connaissais la direction dans laquelle
je voulais aller il fallait que je sois
certain de le faire à ma manière
et donc quand je me suis posé cette
question
doucement
ma définition du succès
a fait migrer l'importance que j'ai
attaché à la réussite sociale
vers l'importance que j'attache à être
comblée intérieurement et j'ai vu mon
envie de stabilité financière de venir
une envie de stabilité émotionnelle et
mon désir d'être reconnu et estimé
devenir un désir de m'assumer de
m'accepter
donc n'hésitez pas à mettre votre récit
au défi
n'ayez pas peur de ne pas croire tout ce
que vous pensez
le deuxième point c'est celui
d'apprendre à perdre
alors il a peut-être qui se diront
qu'ils sont pas encore prêts je vais
vous rassurer
on est tous déjà de grands
on est tous destiné à perdre
on commence par perdre
notre jeunesse notre insouciance
nos amis nos collègues nos parents notre
famille
pour certains en perles aux cheveux et
on finit par perdre dans la vie
et quand on prend conscience à quel
point ce cadeau que la vie est éphémère
on l'a d'autant plus envie
de vivre cette vie à l'autre manière
selon nos propres règles
selon nos propres
donc n'ayez pas peur
d'assumer entièrement cette vie à votre
manière
il y a une approche chez les stoïciens
et cette approche elle est basée sur le
fait qu'on ne valorise jamais autant de
choses qu'on estime jamais autant de
choses que lorsqu'on l'a déjà perdu
et c'est une façon extrêmement juste
quelque part d'estimer notre vie à sa
juste valeur
et nous pousser à vivre cette vie un
autre manière comme on le souhaiterait
le troisième point c'est celui d'être
égoïste dans ses rêves et quand je dis
égoïste j'y vois absolument rien de
négatif et de péjoratif
et j'estime que l'humain est égoïste par
nature et je vais vous donner un exemple
pour illustrer le propos c'est celui de
la mère aimante qui va sacrifier pour
son enfant et on aurait a priori
tendance à penser que c'est l'exemple
totalement posé à l'église et pourtant
quand elle le fait
elle le fait simplement parce que ce
serait bien plus douloureux pour elle de
ne pas se sacrifier pour son enfant
et donc quelque part dans son approche
très centrée sur elle-même son enfant
tient un bénéfice et c'est ce que
j'appelle l'égoïsme altruiste et les
plus grandes réalisations de ce monde
n'ont jamais été que des inspirations de
l'ego si vous prenez les plus grands
innovateurs pour ne parler que des plus
récents comme des Disney des Steve Jobs
d'Elon musk ces personnes là l'impact
qu'ils ont eu dans nos sociétés n'ont
jamais été
que des rêves très personnels et ça n'a
jamais été que des effets secondaires de
rêves très personnel
quand vous prenez Martin Luther King
quand il dit
pas
j'ai un rêve est-ce qu'il y a d'immense
et beau c'est que dans ce rêve égoïste
il a impacté des millions de vies
j'ai une façon très à moi de résumer
cette approche qui est la suivante
je pense qu'à ma gueule mais pour être
bien
le quatrième point c'est celui
de ne pas avoir peur de ne pas craindre
d'être authentique
ce qui vous rend unique c'est votre
authenticité et votre authenticité c'est
ce qui vous permet de révéler votre
talent
et à partir du moment où vous essayez de
ressembler à une autre personne à
quelqu'un d'autre vous êtes certain de
tuer votre talent
il y a tellement de personnes qui
pensent qui n'ont pas de talent
peut-être ici même mais la première
étape elle consiste d'abord et avant
tout
être entièrement soi-même
être entièrement aligné sur ses valeurs
et ensuite grâce à ça on se laisse une
chance de se découvrir des passions et
de révéler son talent
donc n'ayez pas peur de vous assumer
complètement d'embrasser à la fois vos
qualités comme vos failles parce que
c'est la seule façon d'être entièrement
vous-même et de révéler la meilleure
version de vous-même aux autres
mon côté j'ai passé ma vie presque toute
ma vie à penser que la réussite sociale
les diplômes étaient pour moi la seule
voie de réussite
le fils d'immigrés
issu de famille modeste celui qui a
grandi en quartier celui dont les
parents n'ont jamais eu la chance
d'aller un seul jour à l'école
je me suis tellement mis ça dans le
crâne que je suis allé chercher le plus
grand diplôme d'éducation et pourtant
aujourd'hui après avoir quitté cette
carrière de chercheur et mettre lancé
dans l'entrepreneur impact je n'ai
jamais été aussi aligné de ma vie sur
mes valeurs et j'ai jamais été aussi
comblé que je suis aujourd'hui
et mes nouvelles ambitions sont de
mettre l'épanouissement de l'humain en
priorité et de reconnaître les failles
de chacun
dont les miennes sont jamais oublier et
sans jamais abandonner l'idée que chacun
d'entre nous peu importe qui nous sommes
nous pourrons changer les choses changer
notre récit il impacter tant de monde
autour de nous
et en vérité j'ai jamais rêvé la vie que
j'ai aujourd'hui parce que jamais osé
être l'auteur de mon récit jusqu'à il y
a peu
mais aujourd'hui
je ne rêve plus je le vis
alors maintenant que vous savez tout
cela
commencez à écrire
merci
[Applaudissements]